bridles are amazing you're in perfect
health even for you
I'd like a urine sample just to confirm
but everything looks great man you love
urine you love the testing of your
indeed testing of the urine you know
what I meant
why do you have to ruin science it's
good to have you back right back atcha
good to have you back how you feeling I
feel great yeah I feel incredible I
don't know it feels like I've been
reborn hey everybody the flash is back
with a crazy beard so this is gonna be
my Easter Egg video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet there's a new round of the Justice
League
ticket giveaway - all announced a new
winner at the end of this but there's so
much to unpack here who is surprised
that they went straight to thinker like
it's nuts that they introduced him in
the first episode but I actually think
that they did this the right way he's
gonna make Barry run the gauntlet and it
was all a setup to get him out of the
Speed Force
so the thinker is playing everyone
without knowing they're being played
like Cisco wanted to bring Barry out and
this provided the excuse for that
but the thinker wanted this to happen
that's what the samurai was all about
and they named dropped another big
villain to Amunet black the blacksmith
who's gonna be Katee Sackhoff scare
achter who will show up later this
season so let's just go through top 10
WTF comic book Easter eggs starting with
number 10 run
iris run there were so many things that
went back to the first pilot episode a
lot of scenes that mirrored scenes from
the first episode a lot of music hues
the line of dialogue run Barry run was
the first part of that but then number 9
you get the roll into team Kid Flash or
team vibe they're just having a lot of
fun with the idea of what do they call
themselves now and they're doing pretty
good but iris says that a lot of the
people like a giant chunk of the
criminals that they lock up have been
escaping so like they just can't quite
do it without Barry so there are all
these things telling them that they need
to bring him back
the Samara is just the tipping point
like if you don't bring him back I'll
blow up the city we get to see peekaboo
back we haven't seen her I think since
the end of season 1 I love Cisco's line
about hating teleporters given that he
himself is a teleporter he does hate
himself a little bit I imagine but
number 8 we find out what's happened
since last season so we learned that Joe
and Cecile are getting ready
to move in together there's a lot of
weddings that are happening this season
on the shows there's supposedly a second
one Barry and iris are supposed to get
married that's sort of a given in the
big four night crossover but there's
rumors of a second wedding happening and
everybody seems to think that it's gonna
be Oliver and Felicity I don't know if
that's true but that could be
misdirection because Joe and Cecile are
moving in together
maybe they wind up getting married too
but Julian has gone back to London tom
felton I guess just didn't want to be on
the show in Caitlyn has been working at
this dive bar who we learned is sort of
in bed with Amunet black aka the
blacksmith like I mentioned so I'll talk
a little bit about her later in the
video because she's not gonna be a much
bigger deal till later in the season but
number seven even though she's really
nice with Cisco she still has a lot of
problems regulating her killer frost
abilities so it seems like more of an
emotional state that she's in when
somebody pushes her she gets really
pissed off that's when it manifests and
she has some trouble pushing it back
down inside her when she's done with
that so like at the end of the episode
when the douchebag gets up on her and
she's like I will rip you to shreds and
then she runs off like she's afraid like
oh my god please not again I'm not ready
for this
but number six we finally meet the
samurai we learned that Wally speaks
Japanese and I think it's more of an
easter egg for the first appearance of
the samurais from the comics so
obviously in this episode they're being
made and controlled by the thinker but
in the comics there was a person called
Baron katana and it was like a Wally
West goes to Japan type of story like
Wolverine in Japan so while he's saying
that he can do things is just a way of
reminding you that he has a lot of
badass skills too but probably the most
memorable thinker arc in the comics was
from the Wally West geoff johns era so a
lot of the way the thinker looks a lot
of the characters that they're using is
all right out of that so if you want to
read that thinker arc it actually starts
with the flash crossfire story in its
flash vol 2 number 184 I think is the
first one but there's a couple issues
before that and a couple issues after
that but it involves the Keystone City
Bridge which they mentioned in the
episode so there are a lot of verbal
references to things that happen during
that story even though they changed
things for the TV show so we'll try to
point all that out when I post my Easter
egg videos this season but number four
probably one
the biggest comic book things that we've
seen so far is wall-e
in Barry's old costume just like after a
crisis on Infinite Earths when he became
the main version of the flash after bear
had gone into the Speed Force so there
were a couple references in the episode
where people said things like you're not
the real flash you're still Kid Flash
the samurai kept telling him that you're
not the real flash like Wally is not the
main version of the flash so him putting
on the red costume was sort of a wink at
that comic book story and then obviously
him being hoisted up on the katana is
this comic book cover here
Cisco makes a whole bunch of samurai
references Kurosawa was a famous
Japanese filmmaker made a lot of awesome
samurai films reverse Excalibur he puts
the sword in the stone instead of
pulling it out
Cisco's back in the t-shirts don't take
me to your leader but number three they
pull Barry out of the Speed Force using
a team of all the TV shows so you have
Tracy they name-drop her so even though
she's not on the show right now she's
still helping them out from afar you
have Curtis and Felicity you have
Harrison wells from earth-2 all
combining together to find a way to
trick the Speed Force into thinking that
Bear is still there so how could that
not end badly
obviously something later this season is
gonna go sideways maybe that has
something to do with freeing the reverse
flash from the Speed Force they could
take it any number of different
directions and then you have all the
symbols that bear is riding this house
is bitchin I love the joke there so the
whole thing with that is that obviously
there is this secret language I've
already talked a little bit about how
this is like the movie arrival it's this
crazy language they needed to decipher
once they understand it is sort of like
unlocking the secrets of the universe
like Cisco has the Hitchhiker's Guide
joke the universe life in everything the
answer to that would be 42 like the
answer to all these symbols that'd be so
hilarious but the thing is is that you
probably heard a couple lines of
dialogue when Barry was speaking
gibberish that sounded familiar he says
things that happened in the past
so like he says to Oliver I'm not like
you that's a scene from when Barry first
became the flash he talks about needing
more diapers
that's iris and his twins from the
comics so he's referencing things that
happen in the future and things that
happen in the past remember when he was
in the Speed Force time wasn't linear
for him so he experienced all these
different things
so he's just repeating lines of dialogue
that he had previously on the show and
stuff that will be happening later this
season probably it maybe even in the
distant future too but most of the stuff
from the future I think will be from the
future of this season with the exception
of the twins
unless iris becomes pregnant at the end
of this season so Easter Egg for that at
the end of the thinker comic book arc
wally west because remember it was the
wally west era in linda park are married
they find out that they're pregnant with
twins because wally west also had twins
just like Barry had twins
I guess twins run in the flash family
but as far as I know they're only doing
the wedding it would really be speeding
things up for their characters if they
got pregnant at the end of this season
and then they actually try to do
children on the flash but there's a
number of different ways to do stuff
like that so we can talk about it if it
looks like they're actually gonna do it
but for now I wouldn't worry about that
number two Barry versus the samurai so
this is actually pretty cool
iris actually throws herself on that
sword metaphorically not quite literally
just to shake Barry out of his funk
because she knows that he'll always come
save her like she just has faith that's
going to work in that line of dialogue
from Joe pretty much explained what
season four is all gonna be about about
faith about believing in things so turns
out she was 100% correct the weird thing
is that after he runs out you know it's
a really cool scene when he takes the
Sam Roy down is that he says he doesn't
remember how he knew that iris was in
trouble because he's all three-eyed
raven here but that's probably just
because she's his lightning rod they
might choose to explain that on the TV
show but then obviously number one is
that post-credit scene with the thinker
revealing himself all Brainiac looking
so this is sort of an amalgam of the
different looking versions of the
thinker from the comics so they've been
about three different versions of the
character because he's so
technologically inclined and plugged in
looking I'm thinking that they are
sticking pretty close to Geoff Johns
thinker but that was more of a matrix
type story the person working with in
here is the mechanic and obviously this
is all going according to their plan
like he wanted them to bring Barry out
of the Speed Force so it's all very
analytical for them and the thing is is
that he has this plan for making the
world a better place that involves using
the flash so he needs the flash to bring
his plan to fruition so we'll
learn more about that as we get more
episodes but all in all I feel like it
was a solid episode bringing things all
the way back to season one like he
shoots up in bed they ask for the P Cup
they even play the Lady Gaga scene from
season one they have the ferris airfield
so obviously there's a couple things
that are missing from the show right now
Harrison wells hasn't come back yet they
name-dropped a lot of arrow things that
are happening we learned about Katee
Sackhoff slack-smith character that we
might not meet till episode 5 I don't
think it's gonna be till later this
season but before the big crossover but
all in all it seems like it's gonna be a
really strong first half of the season
so everybody let me know in the comments
what did you think about it what will
happen is I'll post my trailer video for
episode 2 tomorrow then I'll post my
legends of tomorrow episode 1 video in
arrow is on Thursdays now so my arrow
videos will post those nights but
congratulations to the latest Justice
League ticket giveaway winner I don't
know how to pronounce your name so black
raikage
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here to watch
berry kick-ass again and you can click
here to rewatch that Justice League
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight